officials in the western Ukrainian city
of leviv say five people were injured
after rocket strikes hit defense and
fuel facilities the attacks came despite
earlier signals from the Kremlin that it
was shifting its focus to the donbos
region in the country's East it's the
third time Russian Rockets hit strategic
Targets in the Vive a city that's been a
Haven for displaced people since the
invasion began
Scramble for cover as missiles hit live
on Saturday
the region had been largely spared major
attacks by Russian forces
the sense of safety in the western City
now shattered
so we were inside the epicenter one
rocket just came so yeah like after that
it was the first time and after a couple
of seconds maybe 30 seconds second
bombing and everyone left to the
shelters I said to my friend that nasty
look at this fire what what is what it
is and then
we heard this this the sound of the
explosion we tried to hide
between buildings when the war broke out
in Ukraine tens of thousands fled to
leviv it's close to Poland which is a
NATO member the rocket strikes coincided
with U.S President Joe Biden's visit to
Poland levieve's mayor says the attacks
are a message from the Kremlin
I think with today's strikes the
aggressor wanted to say hello to
President Biden
who is now in Poland
just 70 kilometers away
I think the entire world must understand
that the threat is extremely serious
ly that was once their Refuge is safe
enough to stay in
DW correspondent funny fashara is in La
Vie for us good morning uh funny
um I'm curious about how you experienced
yesterday's missile attacks on naviv and
how the situation is today
we're in the middle of editing a report
when we heard what first seemed like the
sound of thunder turned out it was one
of the first Rockets actually that hit
live thought really close I have to tell
you it was a very loud bang and it turns
out that this was the Fuel Depot that
was hit and a few hours later followed
by other Rockets now when it comes to
the exact location because I'm being
asked just how far from where you are
it's really hard to say because the
local authorities here but not only in
this state in any part of Ukraine
actually urge people not to share if
they know about the exact location to as
they say vote not to have the enemy not
to help Russia to correct actually what
their target may have been an addition
and to prevent a casualty so when it
comes to that people here at the local
authorities are quite concerned about
some International media sharing
pictures video at the same time of
course they do want the world to know
what is happening so somewhere in
between uh there is the truth then what
exactly happened and but when it comes
to the emotional state of people here in
live they're quite shocked I have to
tell you the day after they didn't
expect that this place that really was
promoting itself almost as the last Safe
Haven here in Ukraine is going to
experience such heavy rocket attacks as
it did yesterday so the war is coming
all too close here as well here just
about 60 kilometers about 60 70
kilometers from the Polish border funny
you mentioned that La Diva has been a
safe haven the last Safe Haven uh
precisely for about 200 000 ukrainians
who fled their homes but do they still
feel safe there
compared to where they are from because
there are so many internally displaced
people that came here from Kiev from
hakif and her son of course they feel
safer than there but at the same time of
course you have to imagine that people
have been staying put for weeks now
trying to figure out their lives should
they cross the border to Poland should
they wait hoping that the war is going
to end soon and they can return so
there's there is this in-between feeling
that's further increasing now because of
what happened yesterday the different
reactions and answers and as a result a
result we do not even know yet what the
impact of yesterday Rockets is going to
be on the mental state of people in
terms of making that decision to
crossing the border which will add to
those two million people that already
left across the border towards Poland
but all around nearly 4 million people
actually left Ukraine already and so
many more are displaced within the
borders so yeah when it comes to the
situation and the State score of live
that used to be quite safe that is
changing as a strategy of Russia
attacking this country is changing as
well
as you well know Ukrainian president
zielinski has again appealed to Western
leaders to send more military hardware
tanks and jets of course what is the
state of Ukraine's Army one month into
the war
when you compare the numbers in terms of
troops and Military of course the Russia
is superior compared to a Ukraine on the
other hand and that shall not be
underestimated people here are quite
resistant I mean you see people who
actually some of them who return to
Ukraine because they want to show
resistance but simply staying here
staying here on the ground and telling
Russia we are not going to give up our
land also when it comes to our soldiers
and the military they did make some
announcements a few days ago that they
could make some Headway and Keith and
other parts of Ukraine the question
really is though at what price that
Headway is being made because at the
very same time people are suffering in
maripole in charity here and so many
parts of Ukraine so the question here
really is not just how much more
prepared or prepared Ukrainian forces
but how what that means in terms of
fighting against the aggressor which is
superior still compared to Ukraine
that's uh DW's funny fish are reporting
from leviv Ukraine many thanks funny
let's bring in Andre osacho he is a
member of the Ukrainian Parliament for
the opposition party uh holos a welcome
sir uh we don't want to disclose your
current location or for for security
reasons of course but we understand
you've personally traveled back and
forth between Kiev and the western part
of the country several times now in the
past weeks how is that Journey possible
right now and what's it like
uh Johnny is still uh difficult but
little bit more easier than it was uh
three weeks ago at the beginning of the
Russian attack because my first travel
when I was taking my three daughters out
of Kiev took me almost 27 Hours by car
usually it is uh distance is taken by
six or seven hours
uh we reduce the number of checkpoints
and block posts all over the country to
simplify the movement of cars and the
mostly humanitarian trucks but train
remain for the moment probably the most
comfortable and more or less safe option
for travel from Kiev to to Western
Ukraine so with car it's still it's
still difficult Mr Saturn given the
consistent bombardment uh that you're
experiencing I'm wondering whether
people in the central part of the
country have the basic resources they
need at this point
I may comment
s interesting for uh outside world uh
you know what is interesting that
probably humans still alive in this
planet because we're very adaptive and
it looks that key of community
almost recover after this emotional
shock of the first weeks of the bombing
and now key with living on more or less
normal life I've just received the
official report from City Administration
saying that for today almost 650 grocery
shops are open 300 cafes are working so
360 car service stations are working 33
markets in the city are open so meaning
that the queue will lives quite normal
life so the traffic is on and I was just
traveling throughout the city like a day
ago
we we tried to live more or less a
normal life for the moment officials say
that it's still about 1.5 million people
inside of the Kiev before the war it was
more than 300 3.5 million people so
essentially Pockets pockets of uh you've
got pockets of normalcy amid all of this
turmoil I want to get to another
question for you sir you posted on
social media that and I'm quoting now we
don't ask the West to die for us but we
asked them to share the responsibility
and pay a fair price for this protection
what exactly did you mean by that
it's very simple uh Vladimir Putin is
attacking the West he was threatening
the West during decades uh he was
threatening West with his uh an
acceptance of NATO uh he was blaming
Ukraine that Ukraine wants to attack
Russia because Ukraine wants to join
NATO and so on and so forth till today
we we made a huge damage to Russia
official report is saying that they lost
582 tanks uh 121 jet fighter 127
helicopter so it's a huge losses meaning
that we consume properly all the Western
Military Support which we receive but
Putin did not refuse from his plan to
destroy Ukraine and to attack the west
and if we all want to save the west and
to keep it as is we want to increase the
support to Ukraine because we are on the
front line of this war and we need not
just defending weapon we need attacking
weapon because we need to capture the
territories which are currently occupied
by Russia so we need more help to
protect West
got it that is uh Andre usachuk member
of the Ukrainian Parliament uh thank you
so much and of course stay safe sir
Gloria doing great
after a month of War many have been
surprised at the strength of Ukraine's
defense but the human cost of the
conflict remains high with the number of
both military and civilian casualties
growing by the day and amid the
destruction people are having to bury
their friends and family in the most
difficult of circumstance
DW correspondent emunesif sent us this
story on a slain soldier dimitro from a
small village close to the Polish border
a house Fallen silent
he was just 20 years old hit by Russian
Artillery on day three of the war
it took weeks for his family to learn of
his death and bring him home
people from all around came to dimitro's
funeral to honor him
foreign
he was a true Cossack and he smiled a
lot he was funny artistic
he always wanted to help everyone he
loved us all so much he wanted to keep
this family together
we'll remember him as an amazing person
and an amazing brother
foreign
the vesutas are a military family
dimitro's sister said their father is
considered by many a hero of the donbass
conflict it seemed natural that her
brother would choose the same path
dimitro's schoolhouse
his teacher received the news of his
death with a mixture of pain and pride
we saw each other for the last time on
the 12th of February and he said okay
goodbye we'll never see each other again
and I said you can't say that
I asked if his death has scared any of
the young men in the village who may one
day have to face the front lines
[Music]
absolutely not it will give them more
courage and strength maybe even make
them angry enough to take on such a
responsibility now nobody is afraid it's
no longer of 2014. now there's a
completely different feeling Western
Ukraine we've always seen military
service as a responsibility a duty is a
duty
a lesson instilled at a young age here
theirs is not to reason why
the cemetery where dimitro was buried
his grave is visible from a distance and
it seems as if it's the very center of
the town
a tragedy but piled high with flowers